What do you do if you're bit by a snake?!
Stay tuned to find out.
Hey there venomous viewers, Jules here for
DNews!
Being bitten by a snake is no laughing matter.
Neither is being stung by a swarm of bees,
attacked by black widows and scorpions, stabbed
by a stingray, or envenomated by a blue-ringed-octopus.
All of these animals are considered “venomous”,
which means that they carry a toxin that can
be injected to produce a harmful response
in another animal.
Now, it’s important to note that although
some venomous animals can be deadly, like
the Box Jellyfish, a huge number of venomous
animals pose little to no risk to humans.
For example, although all 2,000ish species
of scorpion carry venom, only about 30 or
40 of them have venom strong enough to kill
a person.
And your risk goes down even further if you
have access to the right antivenom, which
is sometimes known by its original terminology
of “antivenin.”
Thanks to the prevalence of antivenom, you
are nine times more likely to die from being
struck by lightning than to die from a snakebite
in the United States.
But that’s not true everywhere in the world,
and that’s a big problem.
In Africa, one popular antivenom, which was
used to treat ten types of snakebites in the
Sub-Saharan region, ran out in June 2016 because
the existing stock expired, and the company
making it couldn’t continue producing it.
That’s largely because making antivenom
is an expensive and complicated process.
So, how is it done?
Venoms come in different forms and functions,
with different types of toxins, which is why
there’s not yet a “universal antivenom.”
So let’s take a look at the deathstalker
scorpion as an example of how venoms work.
One of the toxins in this venom is a protein
called “chlorotoxin”.
This acts on cells in your body by blocking
the molecular channels on the surface of the
cell.
In muscle cells, this forces them to tense
up, leading to paralysis, and a whole host
of other negative effects that can lead to
death.
But antivenom is full of antibodies, which
bind to these toxins, changing their shape,
and preventing them from blocking those channels..
The problem is, for many venoms, humans don’t
produce the right antibodies on our own.
Instead, we rely on horses, goats, sheep,
donkeys, rabbits, cats, chickens, camels,
and even sharks to produce them for us.
We picked these animals because they have
immune systems that create the right antibodies
for the toxins.
So to make antivenom, we inject one of these
animals with a diluted form of the venom and
an adjuvant, which is something that helps
create a stronger immune response.
And just like with a vaccine, their immune
system responds, producing antibodies.
The animal’s blood is then extracted and
the antibodies are separated out and used
to treat humans.
It sounds simple, but it requires a lot of
complicated steps.
Getting snake venom requires you to actually
milk the snakes, and it takes many, many,
many milkings — in some cases, tens of thousands
— to produce even just 1 pint of venom.
And after all this work, taking the antivenom
doesn’t give you life-long immunity.
Instead, it’s a form of “passive immunity”,
which means the antibodies aren’t coming
from your own immune system and you’ll need
more antivenom if you get another bite or
sting.
The good news is that researchers are developing
venoms that work on multiple types of species.
In a 2016 study published in PLOS Neglected
Tropical Diseases, researchers created a new
antivenom by taking 12 venom samples, nine
of which were filtered to contain only the
most toxic proteins, and combining them in
a solution together.
This was injected into a horse, and the resulting
antibodies ended up neutralizing the bites
of 18 Asian and African snakes.
Venom is nasty business, but luckily, if you’ve
got antivenom handy, in particular, the right
kind of antivenom, then chances are you’ll
probably survive.
That is, unless you’re attacked by a blue-ring
octopus; there’s no antivenom for those,
so be especially careful when swimming in
Australia and the eastern Indo-Pacific.
Good luck out there.
And if you want to know more about venom,
specifically snake venom, you can check out
this video right here.
So what are you most afraid of being bitten
by?
Let us know down below in the comments and
don't forget to like and subscribe for more
episodes of DNews everyday.